- On this episode, I get pissed off.
(upbeat instrumental music)
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show. ♫
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this episode 150.5
of the #AskGaryVee show
and if you feel the energy off the get,
it's because I'm pissed.
That this is not episode
152 because we did
a very special 360 video episode out there
that you're all gonna freak for.
Because you're gonna be
able to watch the show
and and click and see everything around
and there's a ton of shit going on,
and Vayner people ask
me and it's incredible,
it's phenomenal, but
I taped it two goddamn
days ago, I expected it to go up there,
And the shoot used the VaynerMedia
video production team, not our squad.
But nobody from my squad
said that that wasn't
gonna be up that day.
And then I hear that the end of this week,
or early next week, I'm
like what kind of fucking
timing is that, that
would've meant that I don't
have an episode for
like, eight, nine days.
Unacceptable here to tape episodes.
So I don't understand,
I get angry, then I put
a little pressure, all
of sudden, yeah, okay,
we'll have it at the end
of the day, yesterday,
no-show.
I put out an Instragram picture that said,
you missed the show, it's coming tomorrow.
I looked like a dickface.
I don't like looking like a dickface.
And today, surely, it's gonna be done, no.
I've no show.
And then Steve on the way
back, like, I don't know,
I think you should do something else
because I'm not sure if it's gonna be done
at the end of the day.
I'm not either.
So we're doing episode 150.5,
in between 150 which is the last show
that I did, I don't know,
700 (beeps) years ago.
And this episode that I taped years ago
that's gonna come out one day,
episode 151.
The only saving grace is
that it's gonna be so (beeps)
phenomenal, and then you're gonna watch
it 19 times.
You're gonna try to find
the different things,
maybe your first 360 video
experience in a phone
or on desktop.
You don't have to put on
the Oculus or any of that
stuff, to be able to watch and click.
it's gonna be cool,
but not happy about it.
Just not happy about it.
(laughs)
Ah, that's it.
I'm gonna have a good show.
Gotta have to bang this
one out because I have
to get my Jets prediction
out, alright India.
Let's get into the show.
- Oh, okay.
That's a little better that time.
- Yeah, it was better. Go.
- [Voiceover] Malik asks,
"How could I become a really
"good listener?"
- Malik, I think good
listening comes from actual
intent and actually wanting
to be a good listener.
Like anything in the world,
when you want to beat
something, be something, and beat.
I wanna beat some things right now.
If you wanna be something,
you need to actually
mean it.
Meaning, I decided I
wanted to get in better
shape and health, I just
went out and did it.
Like words are such shit.
You know what's the matter
with a lot of people?
Like a lot of people.
A lot of people watching this show,
a lot of people in the
world, a lot of people,
is there's only actions.
You know I always talk about
intent is what matters,
right?
Like at the end of the
day, I'm publicly tending,
every time of that, I get tons of comments
with like scripture
from the Bible, I think.
I apologize I'm not up
on that, but I think
I'm pretty sure what it's like.
Intense is good for leading things like,
basically it says, intent's great,
but like you can say
you have good intent, but if your actions
are you're doing wrong things, like,
and I get it.
To me, like intent is the starting point
so I think it's nice to start there,
but I agree. I agree.
Words are the problem.
Malik, you wanna be a good listener?
Be a good (beeps) listener.
Like, when somebody's talking, listen.
When somebody's saying something, listen
and try to do that.
Because listening is not just listening,
listening is listening
and then doing something
about it.
Like there's a comma.
The definition of listening
is consuming it and doing
something about it.
The problem is that
most people aren't doing
things about it.
Just a whole lot of talking.
A whole lot of talking
going on in the game.
- [India] Jess.
- Jess.
- [Voiceover] Jess asks,
"I love you man, and everything
"you do, but I also hate
you because I'm a little
"jelly of your success.
"How can I get past that?"
- Like jelly, like Beyonce jelly?
Like, my toned ass, or.
(laughs)
I'm jealous, I understand.
Thanks for the reaction,
you thought I was confused?
I'm not confused.
- [India] (mumbles) How
can I get past that?
I'm jelly of your success.
- Yeah, I get it.
I mean look, I think being
jealous of my success
is good.
I'm jealous of other people's
success, but not really.
Meaning, try to change it from a negative
to a positive.
I'm inspired by people's
success, even though
being inspired by
somebody, and being jealous
of them is literally just
an inch off and they're
cousins, they're kissing cousins.
Being inspired by somebody, being jealous
of someone, is literally
a kissing cousin's game,
and so, I'm too egotistical
to say that I'm jealous
of somebody, but I'm definitely motivated
and recognize, much like the last answer,
the results are the results.
I'm talking big shit, guys.
Like I don't know if you
understand what I'm doing.
I'm really setting myself up for failure.
I've told the world that
I'm gonna buy the New York Jets.
I need to amass 10 billion dollars to buy
the New York Jets.
If I amass 1 billion dollars,
a stunning percentage
of the people watching
the show will define
me as not winning.
Because the narrative has been built,
that this is my thing.
Like, do you understand
that when Woody Johnson
decides to sell, or passes
away, and the estate's
up for sale, in 20, 30
years, god, Woody, 50 years
for you, god bless, whatever, but whenever
that happens, if I'm not
the person at that point
with the narrative I'm
gonna paint all these years
that buys it, people will
be like, oh sorry, Gary,
and whatever the Twitter or the Facebook
of the world then is, which
is gonna be even worse,
because it's probably
gonna be like holograms
and people are just gonna
just pop up and be like, sorry.
I mean, you're literally
gonna have Princess Leia,
58 million Princess Leias
being like, sorry dude,
really wish you got it.
I'm just gonna be loser city USA.
I'm setting myself up
because, what's the question?
- [India] How she was helping--
(coughs)
- Jealous.
Because, you know, you
know because I haven't,
I put myself in such a
weird position of insane
success to justify success
in the narrative that I'm
painting.
So I'm inspired and I'm
challenged by the people.
My friend Travis can buy the Jets.
I mean he did it.
Like this was my homie
that I hung out with
five minutes ago.
Then like, I introduced
that Tahoe Tech talk 2009.
This is the guy that none
of you know on this panel,
but you're all gonna know him,
which I'm trying to figure
out if I'm film of.
Like, it's amazing.
It's amazing.
So anyway, those kind of people.
I'm not jealous of Travis,
I'm inspired that he
executed it at that level.
So I would say that, man,
just like make a little switch
in your DNA and understand, being jealous
of me or anybody else, me being jealous,
you guys, anybody being
je, jealous is a really
backwards defensive trait.
It's gonna do you absolutely no good.
Switching it slightly
into, I'm inspired by that
and I wanna climb higher
than that is a really
good place to go.
So you need to instill
a little more goodness
and get a load of the
badness out of there.
I think the way to get
badness out is to talk it out.
This is why I think everybody
should see a therapist
or have some outlet to get bad.
You needed out, you need to talk out bad.
Bad staying in your heart and soul
will corrode you, and it's a cancer.
Spit out your bad.
Too many people use
their loved ones or their
closest person as the person they spit to,
and that person has a weird
relationship with them.
Find your outlet.
My mom and I use each
other because we're able
to connect.
We got lucky.
We can handle it.
But if you don't have that
lucky relationship,
you need to find a different outlet.
Thank you.
I'm done.
Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Aishwarya
asks, "What lessons, if any,
"did you find from Mad Men?
"How is VaynerMedia differently
run than Sterling Cooper?"
- I don't know who Sterling Cooper is,
I've not watched one minute of Mad Men.
I want to, I think it's kind of cool.
But I've never watched Mad Men,
which is interesting,
because I'm building.
Have you guys watched Mad Men,
or an episode? Do you.
(whispering)
Okay, you, great.
So is Mad Men, is that
agency the one that became
the best, like is the narrative
playing on those years
that they became the big dogs?
- [India] I mean,
they're kind of all good.
- Always were good?
- [India] Yeah, they're
good, and then they're small,
and they're growing this
big company and they
get fired by another company worldwide.
- So I really want to watch it.
You know what's really
cool is that I'm glad
I didn't watch it because
I know so much more
about the ad world now,
that when and if I ever
watch it on a vacation,
on a binge, maybe me
and Lizzie just wanna check
out and like lay in a cabin
in Utah for four days and
watch two shows straight
through, which sounds
really exciting, because
I love checking out on my vacations.
I always laugh, people don't think.
I mean I check the fuck out on vacations,
I don't give a crap's ass.
(laughs)
Yeah.
You like that one?
So I haven't watched
the show, I don't know
what they're doing.
I don't care what anybody's doing.
I'm doing my thing, my
way, always from the gut.
I don't care what
anybody else does, or how
they do it.
My way's always better,
because it's for me,
and I know myself, and
I know I'm gonna win.
And so I don't watch other things.
I don't look at other people.
I don't need any north stars,
I do me the whole way
always all the way through.
Is it gonna be here?
Where's it gonna be?
Here?
- Over my face.
- Over your face.
(laughs)
Go ahead.
- Hey Gary, it's Mark Cuban,
I like to know what your go-to
interview questions are.
Questions you have to ask every candidate
that you interview every time.
Inquiring minds wanna know.
- Cuban's with the nice hat.
I like that.
Mark, who's accomplished
in his life the goal
I have, which is to own
professional sports teams,
I like that.
And a lot of you are fans of Mark
and he's a really smart
dude, knows his stuff.
With interviews, I really
try to reverse-engineer
what the person wants.
I try to break down the
person in an interview
within the first few
minutes of meeting them
to fully trust and believe
in me, which is something
I tried doing to all these
guys on a daily basis.
It's a never-ending battle
from the day I try to interview
to four years into our relationship.
How can I disproportionately
get their trust
because I know my intent and my actions
mapped to doing good things 96 percent
of the time.
And I'd like to think 100, but sometimes
there's a miscommunication
if it is the right thing.
And so I try to get them
to tell me the truth.
Things like, I wanna come
to VaynerMedia to steal
all your ideas and see how you do it,
so I can start my own agency
and steal some of the people
here to start it.
I'm not bothered by that.
I'm like, cool, great.
Staphon, that's your plan.
I'll help you.
I'll speed that up.
But I expect you to work
your fucking face off
19 hours a day for the next three years
for me to then help you
start your own thing.
I don't care what you want.
I don't care.
I want to know what it is, so I try to get
to that place very quickly.
I think the other that
I'm always doing as well
is at the same token as
I'm hearing those answers,
I'm trying to feel out the person.
I'm complete.
When I interview, there's
times where I'm in compelete
Charlie Brown mode.
I'm not even hearing a word you're saying.
It's is want want want
want, I'm just going
by the feel.
The feel is what has
guided me the whole time.
Not necessarily the words,
there's no black and white answer.
I still find it intriguing
that I ask almost everybody
about siblings.
It's maybe because I love
by brother and sister
so much.
And I don't judge if you're an only child,
I don't say, oh, well you
don't work well with others,
all that dumb, cliche shit.
I know plenty of only-children,
the most charistmatic
of all time, and can work with everybody.
And I know only-children
that cliche don't play well
with the others.
I know plenty of jerk-offs
in this office that have 17
(beeps) brothers and sisters
and don't know how to play.
So that's not what I'm looking for.
I don't know even why I
asked that question, Mark,
about the siblings.
But it makes, I'd like to think,
and I explain it's because
of my relationship with
mine and how I like it.
And so it's really the feeling, and trying
to reverse-engineer the person.
That's what I'm looking for, Mark.
Those are the insights, my man.
- [Voiceover] Shannon
asks, "How do you feel about
"Medium's new logo?
"I loved their simplicity
and this new logo's ruined
"that for me."
- Shannon, this is an
interesting question.
I'm an investor for Medium.
That was the first investment we made
in Vayner/RSE when we
transitioned to that world.
I'm a humongous fan.
I'm on the record
thinking that Ev Williams
is one of the less than
a handful executives
in the world that most
understands the consumer
behavior of the modern internet world.
He's proven it Blogger,
Twitter, Medium
he's a beast.
Talk about somebody
that is inspirational
to me, that I'm competitive
with, because straight chops
coming out of every
angle, that being said,
this is one of the single worst
logo shifts I've ever seen.
I was devastated the other day.
I didn't read about it,
I didn't hear about it,
I got on a plane, like my app updated,
and I'm like, where's
my black, what is this
piece of crap?
Holy crap, I hate it.
I'm scared that this is gonna be passed
on to medium employees
and the designer that made
it sees this.
Here's the good news.
It doesn't matter what I think.
I'm just one man's point-of-view.
There's plenty of people that may like it.
I don't know.
Just to answer the question straight,
I really don't like it.
I feel like it blends in
with all the other stuff,
whereas the other one,
now, I could be old man
McGee, and I just got
used to the other one.
I don't know.
But to answer it straight,
I don't like it at all.
But here's the best part
about names and logos.
It doesn't matter.
If they execute on the
product, and the service,
and the narrative, and the user
experience, and the many other things,
I truly believe the
easiest thing to get over
is the name and the logo.
It's the execution.
It's a good way to round
up this whole thing, right?
How do you be a good listener.
You don't talk about it, you do it.
What do you think about this logo or name?
It doesn't matter.
Because what you execute
is what the end result is,
and it just a very good
narrative for this show,
and this theme of 150.5
episodes, which is,
it's about what you do.
Keep talk, you know why I talk?
Because I back that shit up and it feels
double good.
But a lot of you are talking
and never back it up,
period.
And you need to start backing it up.
As a matter of fact, let me
remind you one more time,
I didn't talk shit at all
until I was 30 years old
and I already have the win on the board
to be able to talk about it.
So, for a lot of the
youngsters, why don't you go out
and execute and talk shit.
All of you social media or
life coach experts at 23,
get the (beeps) out of here with that.
And number two, all you
40-year-olds complaining
this, that, and everything,
go do something about it.
You're a grown-ass man.
You're a grown-ass woman.
Stop talking about not
being able to do it,
or it's so hard, or I don't get it,
or it's different, or these
20-year-olds are lazy.
Stop complaining, go do.
Go do.
Doing, doing, execution
is the only narrative.
What you leave on the
table as your body of work
is the game, right?
And that's that.
Simple as that, period.
Good.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Oh, I forgot.
My Jets prediction.
(laughs)
My New York Jets prediction.
I think the Jet's roll in,
Sheldon Richardson's back
number 91, I'm super
pumped to see him back
on the field.
I think it matters.
I think it slows down the Redskin's run.
I do think the Redskins are
better than most people think.
I scouted them a little
bit last week against the Falcons.
They impressed me tremendously.
I do think that, and
they played really well.
I'm a little bit scared
about their defense.
I think their offense
is slightly overrated
in certain pockets.
It's gonna be intriguing match-up.
But I think there's a
chance that the defense
just completely shuts down the Redskins.
I think Cousins throws a
lot of questionable passes
and so I think the Jets
prevail at home 20 to 10
Jets over the Redskins.
See yah.
How much does Rick, the 23-year-old get?
And give me the truth, because the number
isn't high.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, the
owner of the company, I mean
don't know him, but
probably 2, 3 million bucks
compensation this year.
- Explain.
Let's go further.
I wanna know how a
23-year-old gets 2 to 3--
- [Voiceover] I got a company founder.
- Okay.
- [Voiceover] Okay, I'm an
old-school web strategy guy.
I know what works.
- Yup.
- [Voiceover] Send the email,
do the this, put in the time
every day.
So I wanna do that, I will
assist him and it's a communication
problem for me.
- So I'm answering your question.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Why don't you just to it for yourself?
(crowd mumbling)
Yeah, that's the real question, right?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, all right.
- Like cool, if you know what
the fuck you're talking about,
do it for yourself.
I do.
I work harder, and smarter,
than all my 22-year-olds.
I'm better at social media than everybody
at VaynerMedia.
I'm looking at them right
now, just to remind them.
(laughs)
Like so, honestly, I think
you're rolling with like,
trying to razz them.
Razz yourself.
Like why are you trying to follow through
a 23-year-old?
- [Voiceover] That's badass
answer. Thank you.
- Thank you.
(mellow electronic music)